jean françois deniau bonsoir bonsoir
alors vous sortez vos clips donc le
bureau des secrets perdus chez odile
jacob qui est la fille du prix nobel
françois jacob et le professeur testard
perdu bref bébé éprouvette a déclaré
qu'ils voulaient publier deux livres
chez odile jacob
parce qu'elle a publié la paix civile de
charles millon ils l'accusent donc de
banalisation du fn est ce que vous ça
vous a posé des problèmes d'être publiée
sur dit jacob a proposé deux problèmes
d'abord parce que j'avais ça bien avant
que vous évoquez ce problème et raquil
soit évoquée bien avant les autres
publications le dit jacobs et ensuite
parce que contrairement à ce que vous
avez dit je ne suis pas un homme
politique je ne sais plus si j'ai été
viré ou si j'ai claqué la porte
l'un d'eux sont possibles mais je me
tiens l'égard de tout ça j'ai déjà dit
mais l'opinion il faut boire tout et je
recommence donc pas de problème d'être
si odile jacob a donc enfin end et odile
jacob
je veux dire moi ça a été publiée par
des jacob il ya déjà de nous en moi et
c'est pas les nouveaux auteurs ils
peuvent se poser des questions si j'ai
envie de ce fait d'eux les stars bon
alors le bureau des secrets perdus alors
en gros la thèse que vous développez qui
est tout à fait pertinente c'est que les
grands les puissants ceux qui nous
gouvernent n'aime pas à la vérité est
d'ailleurs autour d'eux ils ont des
diplomates des militaires qui leur
fournissent des alibis qui leur
permettent de ne pas prendre de décision
le problème c'est quand les peuples
payent tout ça du prix de leur sang tout
le monde a lu des romans d'espionnage ou
veuillez film d'espionnage et ce qui est
très difficile et très périlleux c'est
de trouver le renseignement nous allons
ramasser dans la réalité moi je crois
que le plus difficile est de l'utiliser
c'est à dire d'avoir le courage de
prendre les décisions alors plus vous
êtes ou dans le pouvoir plus vous
recevez l'information est donc ce qui
compte c'est celui qui va faire le tri
wii qui va vous présenter d'une façon ou
d'une autre ou ne pas vous présenter
l'information est donc ce que la
question que tout le monde peut se poser
sans être un grand spécialiste c'est
pourquoi est-ce qu hitler n'a pas cru
cicéron on en voit là juste là notre
espion
pourquoi je tard il n'a pas cru charges
qui consisteront disait qu en gros c'est
un peu moins que ce que le cinéma lui
raconter mais il donne quand même à
hitler aux allemands le nom de code du
débarquement allié en normandie alors
travers ces précieux parce qu'à partir
de ça vous pouvez été réinterprétés
churchill donc l'unaf accrue il avait
grâce à enigma qui était le décryptage
d'un code et la caudale grand ducaux
attendant il n'a pas cru quand on lui a
dit que coventry qui est une banlieue de
londres aléatoire est une ville cette
vie hors de londres qui est le premier
bombardement par les allemands d'une
ville sans objectif mais on bombarde la
ville et churchill l'a cru d'abord ce
que lui disait enigma et puis se trouve
qu'un aviateurs allemands qui étaient
qui avait été capturé dans un mois le
précédent
on avait mis un mouton dans sa cellule
il dit ça va être coventry il à
churchill un réflexe soyez un peu
étrange mais qu'il faut comprendre quand
on choisit entre 20 informations et ça
c'est trop je me fais rouler c'est pas
comme actrice et londres et je serai
avec les londoniens sous les bombes
là c'était pareil alors vous dites aussi
quant à la fois en 14 est à la fois en
le l'état major français avaient été
alertés sur le chemin qu'on prend très
les vols d'avions nous a poussé deux
fois de suite quand il nous a légué en
14 le plan d' attaques des allemands
très célèbre qui s'appelle le plan
logique qu'un officier allemand qu'on
appelle encore le vengeur masqué qui
veut échanger vous l'importez ou l'a pas
crue parce que ça n'allait pas dans les
idées reçues dans le vocabulaire et je
me suis demandé si par hasard ce
n'aurait pas été la même chose en 40
c'est à dire qu'il faut imaginer la
salle des opérations voyager gamelin
avec le 10 mai 40 des téléphones qui
sonnent et puis les officiers qui
mettent des petites flèches et petits
drapeaux et un moment 1 qui vient de
mettre sa flèche qui s'applique il dit
mais bon dieu je le connais ce mouvement
la main va dans son bureau il ouvre le
tiroir il avait le plan personnes y
avaient cru alors vous raconter qu'on
vous dit que c'est les entourages des
puissants qui trient les informations
est ce qu'on le vrai pouvoir
c'est l'histoire de ceux de ce
responsable du renseignement soviétiques
en en 40 qui avait 2
2 poches de poche ont raconté ce à dire
qu'il y avait eu l'accord dont staline
hitler walryck et dont les entourages de
staline il y avait deux clans ceux qui
disaient formidable génial
staline a complètement roulé hitler et
on peut dormir tranquille ou ceux qui
faisaient attention les allemands faut
s'en méfier
alors le chef des renseignements
militaires qui voyait staline tous les
deux jours préparez de notes une wii 10
est génial formidable
les allemands peu compétition les arts
où les lots qui faisaient attention les
allemands se préparent de l'attaqué il
arrivait dans l'antichambre de staline
où la famille est quoi les gens qui
comptent ce qu'ils ont présenté comme
hanté pendant que l'autre prendre son
petit déj où se rase il sait comment il
est le patron
wes écoute pas de bonne humeur
alors ça tombe sur qu'il a bien résumé
sa tombe sur les allemands donc ça va
bouger gauche ou pas j'aurais nationale
il faut pas se tromper de poche et
charte est la note de la poche gauche
alors avant de passer à vous parce que
vous il vous est arrivé une aventure de
ce type on en parlera tout à l'heure
c'est à dire où vous avez informé le
gouvernement français mais avant je
jouais copier vos mains un moment
important dans votre livre c'est au
sujet de l' affaire dreyfus on ne
manquera pas d'en dire un mot donc vous
en gros votre théorie 1
c'est à dire que c'est un complot
positif dreyfus est en service commandé
pour protéger les recherches au canon de
ce n'est qu'une hypothèse
et dans ce domaine il est écrit telaï
n'y a pas de preuve écrite il ya des
déclarations de dreyfus qui sont connus
qu'on peut interpréter d'une certaine
façon d'une autre l'ensemble des
historiens d'ailleurs l'interprète pas
de la même façon que moi et l'hypothèse
est que le secret du canon de 75 qui va
être une révolution 20 coups à la minute
à quoi il ya 100 ans ce secret battait
cnic oui il est partagé par des
centaines d'ouvriers d'ingénieurs de
contremaître qu'il fabrique qui font les
planctons les essais meilhan plus où il
y aurait eu en plus une manoeuvre
d'intoxication des allemands et ça c'est
seulement cinq ou six personnes ce n'est
pas là mais ce n'est pas l'un des
majeurs dont ce que je dis n'est pas
prendre parti pour dédouaner l'armée ou
pas del valle l'armée
c'est une hypothèse qui simplement peut
expliquer un aspect qui avait frappé
d'ailleurs tous les contemporains
c'est que le capitaine dreyfus tout à
fait aux rites plus dit jamais un mot
contre l'armée a pas du tout il ya déjà
la négation totale
il a même dit j'ai donné au président de
la république ma parole d'officier de ne
pas dire la vérité est assez troublant
c'est troublant c'est un des éléments
troublants
oui ça peut être interprété d'une autre
façon et moi je croyais que parce que ça
correspond à une tradition d'ailleurs
des articles polytechnique que cette
hypothèse m alors donc réfugié dans
votre thèse dillon votre hypothèse est
plus un héros quinqua martyrs en fait ce
n'est pas d'abord un est aussi un héros
et s'il a été très de ses dents dans
l'intérêt du pays le problème évidemment
c'est qu'on avait juste oublié au
passage qu'il était juif et quand il a
été accusé ça a été la question
nationale qu'on connaît je n'ai pas
oublié parce que papa vous avez monté le
complot positif
je crois même que ceux qui ont monté le
complot et son sac ou si c'est en fait
faut dire le nom c'est le général
mercier qui est parti six choisis dans
les dents dans ce qu'on peut accusé de
traîtrise il n'y à mon avis que mignon
il faut l artilleur polytechnicien et un
majeur donc ça faut prendre lanières et
regardez les noms possibles à la cuisse
s'il choisit le nom dreyfus est pas du
tout hasard c'est presque il ya une
campagne déjà riche imiter qui se dit
pratiquement je fais du raid une
cardeuse mais je vous dise est une
hypothèse une hypothèse alors vous vous
voyez comme preuves et c'est d'ailleurs
assez troublant le fait que la première
dotation du canon de 75 a été faite à la
garnison darty au 14e d'artillerie à
tarbes qui était la ville où dreyfus
avait été lesquels le régiment
d'artillerie d'affût voilà et lui je
n'étais encore au bagne donc vous vous
dites si quand le canon de 75 est finie
on le met en premier à tarbes
c'est une façon de montrer disons c'est
un signe je ne suis pas professeur
d'histoire et jamais je n'oserais
employer le mot heureusement que j'avais
je suis un romantique mais déjà tout ça
c'est oui c'est une alors cela dit ce qu
on pourrait vous demander de réfugiés
morts en trente cinq pourquoi il n'a
jamais parlé c'est à dire qu'à un moment
il aurait pu en parler après la première
guerre 35 inscriptions qui est posée est
chez un argument très fort contre alors
vous avez c'est qu'on ne parle jamais
oui vous avez
disons critiquer un c'est pas par un
certain nombre de gens dont jean-louis
lévy qui est le descendant de la famille
dreyfus qui lui effectivement il voit
une réhabilitation de l'armée à bon
compte ces contrats l'instant pas le dr
levy a certainement raison d'avoir dit
ce qu'il a dit mais je ne contesterai
pas l'opinion des héritiers de bacchus
mais il ne faut pas mélanger l'armée est
cliqué tout à fait responsable de tout
ce qu'elle a fait sans aucun doute et
une affaire d'intoxication qui par
définition ces 5 personnes vous avez dit
seigneur pas là mais c'est ce que j'ai
bien compté bien entendu qu'un alors
s'il y a
s'il ya quelque chose dans cette
hypothèse c'est enfin je raconte dans ce
livre d'histoire des officiers bigote
les affiches et bigote ce sont les noms
de code pour les officiers anglais qui
connaissent le lieu et la date du
débarquement signale le lieu et la date
du débarquement
ça veut dire la victoire ou la défaite
mais si les alliés souvient combien
si les alliés sont date sur les plages
de normandie vous c'est fini c'est fini
c'est clair qu'à gagner alors vous dire
l'importance est là dans une opération
il se trouve qu'il ya quelques officiers
qui disparaissent et tout tout tout le
débarquement est suspendu dans de
churchill
tant qu'on n'a pas récupéré les dix
cadavres mais parce que ce serait trop
dangereux que l'un ait pu parler vous
poussez vous dire si c'est très peu de
gens pour terminer faut pas confondre
avec l'armée vous aussi vous avez on
vous a pas écoutés quand vous avez dit
la vérité c'est-à-dire le le dernier
chapitre de votre livre en 91 donc vous
avez le sentiment que la yougoslavie va
éclater vous essayez d'en
de faire une mission parlementaire que
cela vie du mal à leur ministre des
affaires étrangères roland dumas vous la
refuse
vous y allez à titre personnel mais tous
vos rendez-vous sont annulés enfin des
gens la vérité personne veut la voir et
quand vous dites que la yougoslavie va
éclater on vous dit oui mais de rire
et quand vous faites une note en
revenant le quai d'orsay décide de ne
tenir aucun compte
donc vous avez eu le sentiment à ce
moment là d'être exactement dans la même
situation que toutes celles que vous
racontez dans votre bouquin c'est à dire
que vous dites la vérité vous la
yougoslavie avec la terreur des
problèmes ethniques et personne ne vous
écoute vous en voulez à roland dumas
aujourd'hui de 7 ce dédain je serai tout
à fait ridicule de la part d' exprimer
des sentiments à ce sujet il ya une
différence
pas parce que je raconte dans les
chapitres du livre sur staline les
autres où les démocraties comme au
moment d'une hic c'est que moi je ne
suis pas du tout un officiel et je ne
suis pas un spécialiste du renseignement
c'est un sentiment que j'exprime étant
des membres de la commission des
affaires étrangères et que les sens un
peu les questions de politique
internationale et donc c'est je ne suis
pas appuyer sur des bureaux des des
services une administration jeudi voilà
ce qui va se passer
et donc c'est d'autant plus facile et
tentant de dire mais de gnocchi chacune
de ces histoires c'est ce qui s'est
passé ce qui s'est passé comme on n'a
pas envie de voir l'éclatement de l'ex
yougoslavie alors que les yougoslaves 10
c'est fini
lundi c'est fini depuis des mois on ne
tient pas compte de la nouvelle les chez
les chefs et nomen de cours il faut
annoncer que ce qu'est bien vu oui bah
dans le temps de ce que vous dites dans
votre bouquin on coupait la tête des
deux ce qui a porté des messages et qui
apporte une mauvaise nouvelle c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on n'ose pas déplaire et
au passage comme ça roland dumas vous
pensez qu'il devrait démissionner pas
démissionné vraiment je n'ai aucune
opinion sur le sujet je ne connais pas
le dossier
alors si je connaissais le dossier jean
a une opinion mais j'essaye d'habitude
de parler de ce dont je suis donc vrai
comme chirac est réfugié derrière la
présomption d'innocence irak et
président de la république moi je suis
pas président de la république mais
simplement que je ne connais rien à la
faire bon bah écoute et voilà c'est fini
a qu'un truc je vais vous demander avant
de partir parce que plein de choses à
vous à vous dire j'aurais voulu qu'on
parle de votre mère mais ans
votre mère je veux dire quand même votre
mère vous a dit un jour quand tu vois
deux chiens se battre prend toujours le
parti de celui qui est dessous richard
langlais ouais oui parce qu'elle était
australienne d'origine irlandaise
devrait lui prend le parti de chez lui
qui est de chou d'abord et puis après
après tu écoutes les arguments des deux
chiens c'est bien alors il ya une
dernière question c'est y paraît pas si
c'est vrai mais vous êtes quelqu'un de
solide vous avez fait une traversée de
l'atlantique après un triple pontage
coronarien ce qui est vraiment une
preuve énorme de courage il paraît que
vous perdez un peu vos moyens quand vous
êtes en présence de valérie giscard
d'estaing c'est pas vrai il ya
certainement des témoins qui vous en
dise ah ouais mais en fait j'en ai mis
avoue giscard s'épanouir je sais pas si
quelqu'un vous à 10h et sûrement veulent
moi je n'ai pas le souvenir bon et je me
rase j'aime raconter un exemple de notre
coopération sur un point très précis qui
touchait d'ailleurs à une négociation
très importante mais si quelqu'un vous
l'a dit il a sûrement raison
non je les lui mais c'est pas grave donc
c'est faux c'était bien merci tu reçois
maintenant anny duperey pour la parution
au seuil des chats de hasard un récit
dans lequel la comédienne comme hugo
baudelaire avant elle rend un cas récent
hommage à nos petits minous bref du père
et donne sa langue à tous les chats
salut anny duperey alors les chats de
hasard donc le livre on voit pendant que
magie de la télévision on voit partout
parlons c'est un extraordinaire et donc
avec couverture de l'auteur est croqué à
l'intérieur comme gtr2 le terme alors
les chats de hasard sait déjà quoi que
vous avez jamais choisi qui sont arrivés
dans votre vie
oui j'ai appelé les chats de hasard ce
qu'on rencontre qui marque une période
de sa vie où qui qui ont vraiment un
sens tout à coup qui triment dans votre
vie au bon moment et puis enfin en ce
qui me concerne moi j'en ai eu deux
comme ça qu'ils m'ont choisie ou qui
sont arrivés ou que j'ai trouvé et qui
ont justement eu des rapports
exceptionnelle avec moi je me suis
toujours demandé si c'était justement
hasard aussi le fait qu'ils aient été un
petit peu destinée sur ma route ont fait
qu'on a eu des rapports exceptionnel
alors oui j'étais chat qui vous ont
accompagné donc on va parler de votre
vie et puis au fur et à mesure des
événements de volvic et qui est riche en
événements d'ailleurs il faut bien c'est
un livre prétexte faut bien oui et vous
parlez de vous à travers des pc pas que
sur les chats il ya un côté vous avez
pas m'en vouloir dire que tu as peu
mémère à son chat des fois c'est à dire
que quand même ça peut même en avaient
connaissance du retard père j'espère ne
pas l'être
nahla et en même temps il ya votre vie
en contrepoint avec toutes les aventures
qui vous sont arrivés donc évidemment on
va trouver dans on trouve dans ce livre
des choses qu'on avait vu dans le voile
noir on va y revenir jean louis barrault
jean mercure et c'est donc finalement
tout ça est très lié à l'or premier
problème votre vrai nom c'est le grave
et bien fait de changer et eh oui
d'abord il y avait un monsieur legrand a
déjà sûr mais alors du ferry devait
retrouver comme en différé c'est le nom
d'un grand père à moi qui n'étais pas
d'ailleurs mon vrai grand père qui était
le mari bien du mari de ma grand mère
mais c'est un nom qui est dans la
famille quand même c'est un manga dans
la famille bien alors à nyon le moi j'ai
vu écrit trois façons différentes ny
mais il ya un moment où vous l'avez
écrit à m y à 90 peut jamais jamais ont
syntonisé rares d'où est ce que je me
suis dit que la menace est maintenant je
suis né après-guerre donc c'était on
américanisé un petit peu alors c'est le
seul parce qu'après si ginette c'est
comme moi thierry ça faisait comme ça
s'appelait marie victor alors vous êtes
né à rouen premier chat là on y arrive
un premier chat dans un quartier qui
s'appelle les martinsville qu'un
quartier insalubre d'un quartier qui
étaient des touristes
oui avec des usines
de tannage des teintureries un petit
canal et là bizarrement d'ailleurs au
milieu de ce quartier un petit peu
insalubre on l'a dit il ya vous aviez
votre avis y avait un petit jardin c'est
un jardin et dans lequel il y avait
beaucoup de chats c'est vrai que j'ai
été élevé avec 13 h à huy et que j'ai
quitté bond quantique j'ai quitté ce
quartier
et puis j'en ai plus pendant 20 ans mais
c'est vrai que j'ai mangé j'ai revu un
petit peu ma vie et puis en même temps
j'avais envie de parler de nous à
travers le rapport avec les animaux
oui quand vous avez alors ce qu'il faut
dire parce que de toute façon vous
l'avez écrit donc ce n'est pas un secret
c'est que votre père avait 30 ans était
photographe et puis un jour le 6
novembre 55 j'avais 8 ans et votre soeur
patricia cinq mois et tragédie vos
parents meurent asphyxiés dans la salle
de bain c'était le chauffe eau qui était
qui était cassée c'est ça oui si on a
pensé mais c'était oui c'était
d'effectuer tous et l oxyde de carbone
alors vous vous beaucoup culpabilisé
plus tard parce que vous êtes resté ce
matin là dans le lit je n'ai pas bougé
la culpabiliser en pensant est ce que
finalement j'aurais pas pu les sauver
tout ça vous avez écrit un bouquin qui
s'appelle je vous écris qui étaient les
led vous avez reçue après la publication
mais lecteurs qui m'ont
relationnellement libérant je dis ça
parce que sur libéré parce que dont je
vous écris hayatou bip qui vous a dit
vous savez vous deviez être vous aussi
un petit peu intoxiquées un petit peu
asphyxié c'est ça je suis peut-être un
des camps même à d un des seuls aux
auteurs dont la vie a été réellement
changé par ses lecteurs oui oui c'est
vrai oui oui c'est celle qu une des
références janil toujours peut-être d
avoir dix ont laissé mourir
ce sont mes lecteurs qui m'engagent vous
ont déculpabiliser en vous disant fini
mais il pas déjà fait des médecins voilà
vous savez quand il ya quelqu'un qui a
intoxiqué à côté on peut très bien être
victime voilà c'est une merveilleuse
aventure c'est clair mais votre vie
votre vie est tout à fait étonnante
vous aviez souvenir vous
une phrase très belle vous dites c'est
j'avais souvenirs comme un éclat d'obus
c'est à dire comme quelqu'un qui aurait
reçu un éclat d'obus et la pause serait
fermée par dessus un oui alors vous vous
retrouvez les photos de votre père vous
hésité pendant un an avant de les
regarder vous écrivez ça et alors là
quand vous écrivez ce bouquin donc le
voile noir qui a eu un succès
considérable il faut bien le dire 191
c'est là vous vous avez ce chaque ennemi
souhila s'expose alors parler notre
soeur très honnêtement je vais vous dire
je pensais après le voile noir et le je
vous écris qui était la suite de cette
aventure merveilleuse avec le public je
pensais ne plus réécrire et j'ai eu moi
même la surprise là il ya un an au
printemps dernier de toutacoup avoir
envie et c'était pour moi une
merveilleuse surprise parce que je me
suis dit peut-être toute ma démarche
d'écriture n'a été que pour vider cette
chose de deuil et tant mieux si ça a pu
et des autres gens mais ça peut
s'arrêter là j'en étais un peu triste
puisque j'aime écrire mais je suis dit
après tout une démarche peut s'arrêter
là on n'est pas obligé d'écrire quelque
chose s'il n'y a pas de nécessité
et puis j'ai ressenti une très douce
nécessité une très douce nécessité je
crois que c'était une nécessité de devis
il me semble que mon chat de hasard là
c'est la vraie fin du voile oui c'est
qu'en fait c'est vrai qu'il ya eu il ya
eu des je crois être pas être une mémère
achats mais j'ai eu des rapports
exceptionnelle avec how does animaux et
je vais penser tout à coup qu'il m'avait
fait faire des pas dans ma vie tout à
fait étonnant est l'égal d'une personne
humaine est l'égal d'une amitié humaine
donc j'ai eu envie de rendre hommage à
ça et aussi de réfléchir tout à coup à
pourquoi tout à coup on a un animal
pourquoi on en a pas pendant 20 ans
pourquoi il tombe il tombe pas par
hasard dans votre vie et pourquoi tout à
coup on a des rapports avec eux qu'on ne
peut pas avoir avec les humains et mais
qui peuvent compter autant de revers
puisque j'ai crevé le voile noir de
l'émission iquique qui est près de vous
alors après bon compte et ça très bien
dans l'est comme le chat et vieux à un
moment c'est votre si je crois qu'ils
craquent qui prévoit le deuil c'est à
dire devrait en prendra maintenant
c'est oui ma fille a tenté quand il va
mourir a déjà connu ça j'ai pas
tellement envie de a priori de parler de
mes enfants dans les livres et je pense
que ça va ça va s'arrêter là arrêtez de
raconter ma vie maintenant assez pudique
votre bouquin mais c'était tellement
extraordinaire que j'avais j'avais envie
de raconter ça comment effectivement une
enfant qu qui dès l'âge de 6 ans quand
j'étais en train d'écrire le problème
seulement de mes parents mois n'ayant
pas accepté du tout du tout de faire mon
deuil
comment elle a fait tous les spas à
l'avance pour s'accoutumer à la mort non
pas la mienne mais à la mort d'un animal
qu'elle adorait elle voulait savoir
quand il mourrait après elle voulait
savoir comment et après elle a décidé
qu'il mourrait sur elle
ce qui s'est passé elle a décidé qu'elle
apporterait en terre qu'elle irait à
l'enterrement joueuses là c'est dans la
creuse a oui c'est le film de chéreau la
c1 j'ai rendu hommage à ma fille aussi
parce que j'ai je ne pouvais pas
imaginer qu'une enfant est une force à
wray moi je l'aimé pas eu alors bon je
vous parlais du rituel de l'écriture que
tous les gens qui écrivent connaître
chez vous c'est particulièrement rituel
dans quels termes aux pour pas se lever
pour aller boire un café parce que c'est
une occasion d'arrêter de travailler
donc le thermos et sur la table et
stylos cahiers etc
le shaq est toujours gauche et là alors
il vous parlez aussi de votre vie
professionnelle à travers les chats dans
ce bouquin parce que bon ce qu'il faut
dire c'est qu'après la mort de vos
parents est aidé par une tante une
période assez difficile
vous dites on avait des robes qui était
ont refusé les robes à l'envers quand
elles étaient usés oui mais ça c'est la
période cdc les femmes de la guerre et
parce qu'il y avait quand même eu la
guerre de 14 et la guerre de 40 et un
sens de l'économie dans dans le milieu
d'où je viens moi qui étais un milieu
ouvrier ou amener à mieux qu avait pas
d'argent quoi est un milieu paysan même
aussi il y avait il y avait une science
de ne rien nous avons aussi dit un truc
très jolie enfin moi je les ai vus faire
aussi en martyr mais cécile et woods
savonnette qu'on mettait ensemble pour
faire un titre multi colons parce qu'on
leur donnait tous les saints est alors
déjà vous avez quand même envie de faire
du spectacle passé quand il ya des
valses de vienne qui viennent à rouen
vous essayez vous dansez vous savez ça
vous ouais pourquoi je sais même que
vous trouviez au théâtre municipal 15
cour des comptes est mon deuxième
c'était le french cancan à la
foire-exposition de roanne ne savait pas
alors vous êtes premier rang seront
aussi celles à vos talents quand même on
peut les on peut les noter que cette
première en france est déjà une passion
de la peinture et le conservatoire de
rois aux beaux-arts de rouen remonter à
paris je suis de 8 pour très peu de
choses bah si vous êtes doué pour
beaucoup de choses mais entretient
toujours les moins les mêmes les mêmes
depuis le début sur le cinéma le théâtre
la peinture seul coup ça se pare des
textes ouais vous pouvez vous venez à
paris donc en banlieue et là à la
garenne et là vous quand j'étais petit
j'aimais bien écrire et là vous écrivez
à votre tante qui restait à rouen et
jusqu à ce qu elle téléphone vous lui
écrivait biju rien bu de téléphones bas
j'écris un roman
vous écrivez un roman donc et on en
parlera d'ailleurs qu'il est le miroir
qui beaucoup de succès en 76 alors au
théâtre pourquoi je vous parle de ça
parce que vous commencez au théâtre à 18
ans vous faites un film avec godard qui
était ou trois choses que je sais d'elle
parce que marina vlady été votre votre
copine ou donner le vertige à sur le
flash back mais lorsque je ce que je
veux dire c'est que vous avez quand même
au début commencé très bien avant dans
le théâtre puisque elvire popesco vous
choisi pour être la maman auprès d'elle
dans la mama d'andré roule ça et puis là
je sais pas pourquoi est ce que c'est
parce que vous étiez naïf parce que vous
manquez de savoir faire vous vous
acceptez des films qui finalement sont
vous ennuie donc aux non pas du tout pas
du tout c'était de deschacht douce et
très gentille non samassa ne m'a pas nui
du tout j'ai appris pendant ce temps là
j'ai appris j'ai appris mon métier il
faut faire des erreurs aussi peut-être
en ce temps là on n'avait plus le droit
d'en faire que maintenant on avait le
temps de faire ses armes on avait le
temps de faire des mauvaises choses on
apprend beaucoup dans les mauvaises
choses puisqu'il faut sauver sa peau est
alors toujours à cette époque où vous
décidé de revenir comme au théâtre à des
choses un peu plus un peu plus sérieuse
que jerk à istanbul
vous faites hélène donc là vous êtes
dans la guerre de troie n'aura pas lieu
avec jean mercure et là vous raconter un
truc terrible dans votre bouquin c'est
qu'on mercure vous parle de l'élevage
des veaux jour batterie mais vous savez
il ya un point commun il ya je crois que
les gens les gens qui manie beaucoup la
séduction la large veut dire les idées
comme comme ces créateurs qui était
quand même des metteurs en scène et où
il ya c'est là où ça va donner à
réfléchir quand même sur les liens
qu'ils ont avec les animaux c'est cela
que j'ai vu le plus sensible aux
rapports simples et avoir une véritable
fin vraiment un besoin fondamental de ce
rapport je vous assure le visage de jean
louis barrault qui est toujours un peu
[ __ ] vous savez comme ça quand il
regardait son chien c'était
extraordinaire parce que cet oeil
toujours un peu à la chinoise comme ça
devenait complètement rond il était tout
à coup complètement apaisé comme si
comme si comme si quelque chose de très
profond et est en train de s'abandonner
au contact de l'animal et on a tous
besoin de ça jean mercure vous dis donc
je vous parle des veaux en batterie mais
ça m'a beaucoup enfin gentil c'est
choquant parce qu'on sait pas vraiment
xevo sont élevées dans le noir avec les
pattes et qu'un terrible c'est terrible
et que les animaux se venger quand on
voit ce qui se passe maintenant
effective effectivement oui c'est pas ça
qui m'a dit exactement ça m'avait aussi
beaucoup frappé et m'a dit la souffrance
transmet oui dit je suis persuadé que
une torture qu'il ne véritable torture
quand même d'élever un être jeune un
veau gère dans le noir sans bouger juste
juste l'empêcher de bouger je dire
l'empêché de voir la lumière
est une torture total edit je suis
persuadé que la souffrance reste
inscrite quelques bières et quand on
mange une chair qui est imprégnée de
souffrance il en reste quelque chose et
j'ai été choqué dans société
c'est beaucoup mais bon voilà alors on
va parler du mot terminer sur les
bouquins dont il admire war en 76 du
prix de l'académie française quand même
pas rien le nez de base à 5,81 cependant
un des prix un des prix le nom de
mazarin 86 le voile noir 91 avec je vous
écris derrière et puis aujourd'hui le
dernier donc les chats de hasard voilà
la boucle est bouclée vous croyez non
maintenant par contre je pense que non
je vais écrire
ouais je vais écrire mais je pense que
je vais je vais peut-être revenir à la
fiction oui parce que c'est très
agréable faut dire que nous nous
comédiens
c'est vrai qu'on joue avec soi même avec
son tempérament avec ce qu'on pense ça à
travers des personnages un coup je me
montre que je me montre pas c'est
toujours sur une fiction alors comme je
le fais dans mon métier c'est vrai que
c'est s était formidablement tentant
tout à coup de parler directement aux
gens que vous avez de la chance de
pouvoir tout faire comme ça c'est
formidable c'est par je le fais avec
coeur ruine le dis et je suis ravi que
les gens le reçoit bonsoir vous mettez
en 1936 aux buttes chaumont
c'est ça en 36 vous étiez en quelle
année oui en 36 mais pas au but aaa
funés au métier d'acteur au but mais je
suis dit ah baudelocque mclane les
parisiens dans le 14e avant d'accord
soit que j'étais votre enfant s'est
passé là-bas alors il ya un flou sur
votre enfance toujours c'est à dire que
vous êtes parti quand et comment dans la
creuse basque partie à cause de la
guerre les allemands
oui c'est ça cause également à cause de
deux de mes origines
je dus me dit vous cacher en fait c'est
comme le vieil homme en moins oui me
cacher ses seins et j'ai été caché dans
une famille creusoise d'accord c'est ça
ouais donc parce que là nous c'est non
de votre mère en fait ça vous est pris
dans le dos alors on est obligé de
partir donc et vous êtes sûrement ce qui
explique un peu votre personnalité parce
que vous êtes très obsédé par l'identité
cette idée d'avoir dû partir ça a dû
vous marquez vous dites l'identité c'est
la plaie de la vie on ne sait pas par le
par la notion ne s'est pas la notion de
partir qui vous fait dire ça je pense
pas une identité je parle de
l'attachement qu'ont à asseoir et je
pense que plus on s'attache à soi même
plus en plus on a des difficultés à se
quitter
c'est donc dans une optique vers le
personnage dans le film i déchéance le
personnage dans le film la pression
d'escargots ils disent pour ça que c'est
très lié il dit j'ai passé ma vie
séparer de moi de moi même on est passé
d'aidé qui s'adonnent au oui moi j'aime
cette notion de même que j'aime pas la
notion de possession
ouais je n'ai rien à moi ouais je ne pas
posséder quoi que ce soit de même je
n'aime pas je n'aime pas me posséder
c'est bien je considère que qu'on est
trop fragile pour ça et mon rêve ce
serait de ressembler à cet homme en
marche de giacometti qui est également
cette même des marins m ca de rendre
l'homme de rendre l'homme à l'état de
rien surtout surtout d'éviter qu'ils
offrent une prise quelconque au vent
alors vous allez donc pendant la guerre
dans ce petit village s'appelle la
chapelle taillefer ou pas c'est la
guerre là-bas ça vous a aussi inspiré
beaucoup parce que vous dites j'ai votre
mentalité un peu de paysannes comme ça
vous dit je suis le sillon quoi c'est un
mélange à la fois de nomadisme et de et
de mouvement on prend partout non mais
c'est bien alors vous redécouvrez en
plus ce qui est bizarre la région 25 ans
plus tard vous y retournez dans un
élevage de la creuse et vous habitez
maintenant à 50 mètres de la ferme vous
avez dit ces bergers quand vous étiez
petit quoi exactement
cécile en fait je ne savais pas qu'il
était poussé des restes mais c'est bon
pour l'identité tout ça après mais la
nature est belle ouais alors à 19 ans
vous engager dans les parents en algérie
ce qui fait quand vous avez fait dupont
lajoie finalement vous connaissiez des
personnages
vous aviez répéter le rôle 1 vous êtes
partis dans les paras pourquoi veux tu
es un peu voyou oui j'ai description
maintenant prêté à ces voyous j'étais
j'avais rien wedge avait pas de métier
rien du tout donc je traînais mais mes
godasses est très souvent même je
marchais à côté parce qu'il y avait plus
de talent on inclut 2 contre fauré et
donc qui j'avais des copains des copains
qui avaient un an ou deux plus que moi
et qui use s'était engagé en indochine
certains étaient morts en tout cas il
revenait avec des médailles les rouges
de parent etc
et moi je me disais pourquoi mes copains
ils vont là bas et moi j'y vais pas cela
en regardant de chine à cesser
puis pour coup le monde johann ont lancé
cette algérie où il commença sa cause et
celle d'algérie aux effets comme les
copains vous êtes c'est plein de boulot
sarthois vous restez quand même trois
ans vous revenez à 22 ans vous fait
plein de boulot dans l'ouest celle ci a
triché farman en faisant toujours la
même pièce toujours la même pièce sans
savoir à quoi elles servent et c'est
vraiment un exemple de l'aliénation
ouvriers on peut le dire et à 25 ans
vous avez pas lu de livre vous n'aviez
pas vu le film
vous étiez à ces incultes oui et la
porte
ouais c'est ça et là votre votre nicole
vous avez attendu vous vous faites un
enfant vous retrouver à trois dans une
chambre de bonne foi c'était quand même
vous avez galéré voir vraiment ouais
j'ai bouffé de la vache enragée et là un
jour vous êtes machinisme j'adore ces
histoires cette machine sur notre dame
de paris
or le vrai un anthony quinn anthony
quinn le film de delannoy donc le vrai
d'être machinistes et là vous dire je
vais faire l'acteur quoi oui bah oui
parce que je savais pas quoi faire de ma
peau et j'étais là sur mon sur la
passerelle je regardais d'abord le matin
je voyais arriver pas le matin au
chômage étaient là dès 6h30 lui
l'arrivée à 11h30 anthony quinn dont une
superbe cadillac rose hill a eu sur le
plateau on lui avait mis un truc d'une
bonne dose zeeuw
j'ai dit ça je peux le faire donc partir
là je me suis dit je vais faire ça ouais
et donc j'ai décidé de faire l'axé
fellini quand ils racontent souvent
l'histoire un moment il va sur szczesny
cheetah y voit un type qui disait
sandwich 4 fait matin il dit c'est qu'il
évalue les deux réalisateurs il dit je
fais réalisateurs comme ça que naissent
les vocations
au début vous
c'est moins fatigant de faire l'acteur
que de monter sur les échelles et puis
après on s'est aperçu quand même que
c'était un boulot hein c'est à dire que
j'ai fait avec le métier d'acteur une
sorte de mariage comme s'arrête
un mariage inconscients qui était
certainement pas un mariage d'amour et
petit à petit il s'est transformé devenu
un mariage de raison donc jamais à le
raisonner pour le faire correctement
et aujourd'hui je crois que tu es passé
vraiment à lamoura bah oui et non oui
alors c'est très touchant aussi c'est
qu'on voulait faire l'acteur vous
commencez par des coupes et des pour
avoir des cours par correspondance dans
cinéman quoi je dire simplement le béaba
vite rejoint deux seuls acteurs qui
aimeraient qu'ils aient pris quand même
un an de cours par correspondance en
asie toujours ton permis tu l'as lu par
correspondance vous voilà et alors vous
là où vous commencez à vous sentir vivre
c'est quand vous rencontrez pierre
richard et vous faites un de ces duos de
l'époque maintenant les gens se
souviennent plus moi je suis assez vieux
certains y avaient d'arras et noir et
c'est richard et là nous là mais charrie
la nouriture et là nous voilà et là vous
faites tous les cabarets alors il y
avait les cluses le port du salut et
camarines larigot et c'est sa galerie 55
que ce qu'ils avaient encore will le
port il y avait yoann qui était dans
l'arrivée du fils où il va le cheval
d'or voilà il y avait béni l'échelle de
jacob balle à une époque bénie et est
donc vous faites ça donc là ça se passe
pas trop mal
vous étiez avec la saison il faut payer
qu'un steak frites mais bon et georges
brassens vous permet de faire vos dettes
américaines à bobino à georges était un
petit peu vent nous nous aimait bien on
avait fait une fois un spectacle en
première partie
et puis ils nous avaient apprécié et
puis on avait beaucoup sympathisé
vous êtes des boeufs on faisait de la
musique entraîne de représentation et
puis finalement on a beaucoup suivi ces
deux ou trois années dernières années où
il a travaillé à bobino ben il nous
demandait de faire la première partie
pour nous c'était formidable d'abord
parce qu'on était dans un climat très
basse et puis ça nous a permis de créer
des choses d'être bien alors après on
fait du théâtre ou pas tout raconter tnp
planchon vais jouer des classiques des
jouets
vision comique le premier le premier
rôle il faut le dire en 64 ans 71 deviez
fait votre premier film qui était la
vieille dame indigne de rené allio et
après cela vous faites un film c'est la
vie normale d'andré charpak
j'ai pas vu le film je critique pas le
seul trois mille ont marqué et là vous
avez un trou de 8 ans quand même bah oui
j'ai un trou donné un petit peu moins de
8 ans mais j'ai un gros trou quoi je
serais un gros trou et vous revenez en
71 dans le rôle de gustave dans la
sphère dominici voilà que ça a été quand
même
après laurent pas parler de tous vos
films on les connaît on les aime et
dumont la joie que nous un cousinage
vieux poulet un éléphant ça trompe
énormément nous irons tous au paradis
est ce que les gens savent pas si vous
êtes auteur de théâtre et qui deux
pièces le tournis quels périls bleus oui
j'en ai écrit deux eaux d'une troisième
oui j'ai écrit une autre pièce prêtera
ritournelle à la ritournelle qui devait
s'appeler rétrospective qui s'appelle la
ritournelle et dernièrement systems
plaidera mon concert que j'ai créée au
théâtre hébertot
alors ces pièces sont traduites en 17
langues enfin au moins pour les deux
premières que j'ai cités vous a pas
rapporté beaucoup d'argent mais elles
sont traduites en 17 langues ce qui
prouve quand même la localité visitée
plein de trucs pour ça que j'ai tout à
l'heure vous parliez du personnage de dd
dans le film de muscat salle mais vous
avez produit des premiers films d'une
boîte de prod s'appelait les films de la
droite vous ai créé une société de
distribution de cassettes vidéo exact
est encore pire que tout vous avez
financé de la recherche sous marine au
large de saint malo pour glamour mais
pour trouver des épaves
oui c'est une rencontre et une bande de
gars qui travaillaient sous l'égide du
musée de la marine parrainé par
profession mono qui m'ont dit on fait de
la recherche archéologique vous pourriez
faire des films sur nos travaux ça nous
permettrait de continuer de vos travaux
vous vous prendriez je prenais ma
société de production allait m vous
prendriez les bénéfices des films et
puis vous financiers nos expéditions
c'était dans l'air et ils m'ont wind et
en barbarie alors j'ai vendu la maison
et lula avec la droite
non mais c'est clair alors on parler de
terreur de votre réputation d'ours qui
est qui en fait une façon d'une façon de
vous protéger mais bon c'est ça en fait
parce que vous n'êtes pas un jeu
comme les gens qui me connaissent savent
que je n'ai pas de griffes avec moi
c'est la première fois que je vous
rencontre je veux dire vous avez
particulièrement à sympathique ça sert
exercice non mais c'est vrai aussi il ya
vraiment à moi aussi ça c'est plus rare
comme le disent oui et alors et là
maintenant alors vous vivez dans la
creuse donc vous mêmes votre
pied-à-terre à paris là non on vivait
dans la creuse et vous dis que je
regarde l'herbe pousser voilà chez
devenu contemplative voire mystique
c'est ça oui
fillon n'a pas parlé du maillot c'est la
télé mais j'ai toujours été un petit peu
mais là je ne suis de plus en plus je
pense que j'ai perdu beaucoup de temps à
parler de la vie ouais
à écouter les raisons de parler de la
vie et pas suffisamment de temps à la
vivre ouais
et donc maintenant que le temps presse
j'ai décidé de vivre et vivre c'est
comme la chanson c'est oublier oublié de
vivre enfin donc voilà donc je n'écris
pas je donne je ferais vous dites je
préfère regarder l'herbe pousse et qu'on
peut mettre à ma table de travail on
appelle ça c'est parce que c'est plus
important il ya à l'époque de la dhr où
êtes vous aviez un tableau dans votre
bureau qui était un tableau de m6 et
cher qui est quelqu'un qui est un
dessinateur magnifique à la pointe sèche
comme ça et vous aviez déclaré on
restera là dessus je suis l'homme des
perspectives un petit bout si vous
n'avez pas trouvé votre trajectoire
voulais dire dans la vie vous je pense
peut-être aujourd'hui je je pense
aujourd'hui l'avoir l'avoir trouvée je
crois qu'il me pousse espèce de flamme
qu'on les étoiles filantes
mais c'est toujours et wall e filante
ouais bien m'écouter merci en tous les
cas je très heureux de savoir nous avoir
connu on se connaissait la cie prologue
je reçois maintenant l'écrivain et
scénariste jean claude carrière pour
l'adaptation au théâtre de l'atelier de
sa controverse de valladolid un dialogue
dans lequel carrière décrit une querelle
idéologique historique ayant enflammé
l'espagne des conquistadors les hommes
du nouveau monde sont ils des hommes
comme tout le monde
bonsoir mon frère
alors ben oui non ce que je vous disais
tout à l'heure la sadur quoi 2h 2h 10
2h10 à peu près aux gens sont scotchés
oui parce que cette question que vous
que vous posiez très bien sont ils des
âmes
ont-ils des âmes de même qualité que la
nôtre étrangement soulève et est
dangereusement sous la main et qu
aujourd'hui
alors on va pas vous présenter aux
fesses théâtre cinéma télévision livre
chanson vous êtes un peu le faisait
d'une curiosité absolument nature et les
rentes vous êtes le conflit est ouverte
aux échos français ça vous écoutez nous
connaissons bien nous avons même fait un
livre ensemble
récemment je n'ai pas sa science et
c'est à dire umberto est vraiment un
sémiologue c'est un savant mais très
souvent nous nous rejoignons dans des
curiosités en et erika cela ne réussisse
à chantons ensemble nous avons un numéro
de duettiste après quelques bouteilles
emballages les chansons de corps de
garde avait d'ailleurs si vous avez une
cave aussi mais pas là pour parler de ça
nous fait une super cave
alors donc c'est une la controverse a
été créé pour france 3 c'est ça oui
c'était d'abord un film de télévision
que j'ai non pas adapter mais re écrit
pour le pour le théâtre en de
développement beaucoup et surtout en
enlevant l'aspect un peu théâtral juste
à dire l'aspect salle capitulaire avec
des spectateurs
là ça se passe comme ça s'est passé
vraiment apparemment à valladolid dans
un couvent dominicain valladolid qui
était la capitale de l'espagne donc du
plus grand empire 2 mais c'est du temps
de charles quint il ya une manière un
peu clandestine un peu secrète c'est à
dire dans les cd pour les 500 ans de la
découverte de l'amérique en 1992 dans
legends cars mais il est marié levé
trintignant et là jacques weber
lambert wilson et bernard verley dire
qu'ils sont excellents sincère je trouve
que webber est complètement habité par
son rôle j'ai jamais vu comme ça il est
complètement dedans là je crois que ça
tient beaucoup au travail que jacques
lassalle de mer en scène a fait avec les
avec les comédiens pendant longtemps il
les a vraiment très bien installés à
chaque moment dans leur position ils
savent très bien oui l'ont fait et ils
savent très bien ce qu'ils défendent et
savent très bien qu'ils doivent le
défendre avec la plus totale sincérité
comme le faisait ces personnages là y'a
pas des bons et des méchants ne leur ont
pas des juges
et justement alors mais voilà ces sites
une réflexion comme vous avez dit qui
est qui et qui est absolument actuel
alors c'est ce qu'ont affrontement entre
deux hommes enfin ce qu'on appelait le
d'une dispute
1 c'était une dispute parce que nous
sommes à une époque pré scientifique
oui on a pas moyen il n'y a pas de
moyens biologiques d'affirmer s'il sont
les mêmes que nous la seule possibilité
c'est de déclencher des controverses et
de voir à qui dieu va donner raison et
intérêts car nous vivons une époque où
tu non seulement tout le monde croit
quand dieu ce qui aujourd'hui est
difficile à concevoir
mais où tout le monde croit que dieu
intervient constamment dans les affaires
humaines et que s'il a permis la
conquête du nouveau monde à une poignée
d'espagnol et 300 les ouailles de deux
grands textes étaient un million et un
million c'est que c'était son intention
de les aider par tous ceux qui à
l'intérieur de cette de cette vidéo on
essaie de déchiffrer les desseins de
dieu et ensuite il faut bien aussi voir
colette à une époque où les livres de
médecine des médecins le plus célèbre de
l'époque y compris ambroise paré sont
pleins d'histoires de femmes qui
accouchent de crapaud ou qui font
l'amour et des crocodiles etc la
sentence 1 oui par l'allemand d'ailleurs
que les saint juériens des visionnaires
en france est exactement la notion
d'espèce biologique n'existe pas encore
il faudra encore plus de deux siècles
avant que ça se dégage ce que voulait
dire en fait j'étais légitime d'une
certaine façon à l'époque se demander
qu'est-ce qu'ils indien était un être
humain oui c'est pas légitime c'est
normal c'est naturel alors on fait des
tests sur repos verra s'ils ont la même
pensée le même sentiment que nous parce
que tout ça repose sur la pensée
d'aristote il faut dire à quel point
elle rire ji selon moi je vais resituer
pour les gens qui sont pas au courant
donc il ya un légat du pape qui joué par
bernard verley qui est envoyé par le
pape et par charles quint pour justement
statuer si le savoir est ce que les
indiens sont doués jamais ce qu'ils ont
une a statué pour la dernière fois car
l'église a déjà dit qu'ils avaient une
âme
mais ces instructions n'ont pas été
respectées donc il faut maintenant faire
le point une fois pour toutes voilà
alors là il ya effectivement c'est
sepulveda qui est jouée par lambert
wilson qui lui justement philosophe
voilà alors c'est là où j'ai vous
demandez pas ce que aristote
comment jacques weber enfin bartolomé de
las casas lui dit à un moment
attendez vous nous parlez d'aristote
marie stone depuis aristote qui avec
jésus-christ bon eh oui alors ça c'est
pour notre gouverne personnel
expliquez-nous ce qu'était la pensée
d'aristote le plus brièvement possible
dans ce domaine là oui dans ce domaine à
aristote dit que dans l'espèce humaine
il y à différents degrés et que
certaines espèces humaines certaines
catégories sont nés pour servir les
autres et que par conséquent certaines
catégories sont nés pour commander les
autres et s'en servir donc cette idée là
et apparemment tout à fait contraire à
l'évangile
oui car la parole du christ dit que tous
les hommes sont aussi claires sont un
autre prochain c'est alors le grand
effort de l'église au moyen âge a été de
concilier la science grecque car on ne
peut pas nier que les grecs étaient de
grands scientifiques au sens que l'on
donné à ce mot est la pensée chrétienne
saint thomas d'aquin y est arrivé voilà
ce que je vais vous livrer un saint
thomas d'aquin respecte encore des
catégories d'aristote
mais maintenant alors on arrive à l'est
au 16e siècle à l'époque des grandes
découvertes le monde
on le voit au niveau des navigateurs
font le tour du monde
on rencontre d'autres peuples les temps
modernes perse et d esprit pionnier
comme las cases qui après qu'une grande
partie de sa vie là-bas car est 14 fois
la traversée de l'atlantique c'est un
but c'est un vieux baroudeur commence à
dire est très fortement
il est aussi l'auteur c'est une parole
de la sq synagri aristote et 1 alors que
maintenant il faut vraiment respectée
aujourd hui dans le monde il ya encore
des gens parce que moral c'était très
inspiré d'aristote et de saint thomas
d'aquin
est ce qu'aujourd'hui dans la pensée
dans la philosophie encore des gens qui
sont même est naturellement mêmes et
même officiellement avait pas seulement
dans d'autres pays y compris chez nous
alors cette pensée n'est pas nettement
formulée elle mais elle est
politiquement incorrect le club de
l'horloge par exemple ils sont inspirés
d'aristote et saint-thomas d'agrément
certainement ils ont une base je ne les
connais pas je vous avant de vous en
parler mais certainement ils ont une
base idéologique de ce type là c'est
très laid pensée évoluent elles prennent
des formes nouvelles de notre temps on
n'irait pas à affirmer comme le faisait
ces pôles débat les
chose mais de voir les spectateurs dans
la salle tellement accroché par ce débat
d'idées mais pendant 2h15 on s'emmerde
pas une sinécure associations rue la
chose importante il ya des liens et puis
il ya ce et c'est relativement
mouvementée mais ce qui m'a j'ai envie
de dire toujours que malheureusement
c'est un débat toujours d'actualité même
si la pensée a pris d'autres temps et
fort oui c'est par exemple on peut dire
aujourd'hui que nous sommes de même
nature égal mais que nos cultures dit et
qu'il a des cultures supérieur aux
autres
ça aussi c'est très dangereux on n'a pas
encore assimilé notion de pensée sauvage
journal quelques énormes ce qui est bien
à bagnols
eh bien oui et ce qui est bien ou
l'espagne ce qui est bien dans votre
pièce et que évidemment tout le monde
est d'accord tout ce qu'on aime bien
weber 20 personnages de las casas parce
que voilà il est magnifique il dit mais
les indiens sont mes frères et c'est
l'autre c'est un rôle un peu plus
difficile lambert wilson parce
qu'effectivement lui soutient des
pensées qui nous choque qui nous choque
c'est clair mais ce qui est bien c'est
que c'est plus vénales ce n'est pas une
ordure dans votre billet et lundi encore
très il ne le fait pas du tout par
intérêt personnel voilà c'est pas
manichéen malargé bien c'était ma manie
rien voilà à sa façon il le fait dans
l'intérêt des indiens puisqu'il met
avant tout le sable blanc et si l'on dit
que le salut de l'âme
c'est à dire la béatitude dans
l'éternité est beaucoup plus important
qu'une vie brève
il est très tôt frappé par la mort alors
il a raison de faire ses arguments dans
la mentalité du temps sont irréductibles
et souvent avec la précède un peu des
fois à un moment il dit sepulveda a dit
oui m'enfin avant qu'on arrive nous ils
massacrent il sacrifiait des gens à leur
dieu et à ce moment là il y avait vers
enfin las casas qui dit m'enfin bram
était bien après ans clément tuer pour
s'est tout de suite annoncé mon
cheminement intellectuel il ya des
choses qu'on voit toujours
malheureusement derrière ce thème on
voit le kosovo on voit beaucoup de
choses aujourd'hui
par exemple quand le légat dit mais
pourquoi intervenir chez les autres
commente ces sacrifices humains oui
comment les distingueront nous d'une
simple condamnation à mort est comment
ferons nous est ce que le fait que nous
adorons le vrai dieu nous donne le droit
d'intervenir partout d'un radier des
problèmes qui sont extrêmement complexes
alors effectivement quand on voit cette
pièce et puis moi je les ai vus samedi
soir dimanche
avec jean paul ii qui faisait une messe
parce que las casas était évêque du
chiapas l'endroit où c'est incroyable de
ce commandant mark wallace l'endroit n'a
pas bougé c'est toujours les mêmes
problèmes la même effervescence et des
filles mais c'est qu'un million
d'indiens et on se dit quand même que
bartolomé de las casas a gagné parce que
la maintenance et le pape qui fait ça
m'a beaucoup touché 100 soyez h pour y
aller je sais si je n'ai pas beaucoup
plus mais ce peuple mais je dois dire
que dans les derniers mois aux dernières
années de sa vie il a maintenant une
attitude qui est qui et je ne sais pas
si c'est la maladie ou l'âge qui l'amène
à ça mais ce qu'il a fait au mexique
cette fois est très louable
oui et vous savez d'ailleurs que la
capitale du chiapas de l'étape s'appelle
san cristóbal de las cases
ah oui à cause de la durée son nom et la
photo le maire donnait son nom cette vie
très bien alors avant de avant de
continuer cette interview et qu'on
regarde un tout petit extrait comme ça
pour resituer un petit extrait donc de
la controverse de valladolid de jean
claude carrière magnéto dans un nouvel
ordre toutes les raisons d'être triste
il souffre d'être loin de leurs terres
la controverse de valladolid donc au
théâtre de l'atelier très beau théâtre
magnifique endroit alors j'ai pensé en
voyant ces indiens sur scène au grand
père de 42 qui a été choisie vous
connaissez ça il était amené son
grand-père avait été amenée de nouvelle
calédonie en france pour une exposition
universelle quelconque au début du
siècle et donc son grand père a été
comme ça exposés à la vue et au toucher
de tous les visiteurs et quand il en
parle il est très bien vu des
expositions coloniales jusqu'en 31 oui
c'est ça à 31 ans seulement la plus
grande s'est étranglé un oui et on
emmenait de là c'est un peu choquant
quand on emmène les indiens pour faire
des expériences sur eux quoi pouvoir
comme des poteries oui comme dd oui
voilà on regarde s'ils ont peur sillery
enfin un truc fort je faisais la même
chose
alors quand vous donnez vous et moi pour
aller mais lorsqu'il faut dire c'est
qu'il ya une chute en plus c'est à dire
qu'il ya deux chutes et une double chute
alors évidemment il ya la raconterai je
manquais de nec est attendu d'ailleurs
ce mal art et essai puis il ya un rebond
didier un rebondissement incroyable
voilà qui va entraîner enfin une
catastrophe mondiale après que je
voulais vous remercier vous m'avez fait
passer un excellent moment et puis je
pense que nos amis téléspectateurs qui
me croient un peu il rompt voilà alors
bon votre vie est assez connu il ya un
truc qui est formidable dans votre vie
quand même et moi je sais que finalement
bon vous avez commencé vous étiez votre
père était vigneron et quand vous étiez
tout petit vous ramasser des châtaignes
mettait dans un collège de saint lary de
lazari d'ariste et finalement c'est
l'endroit où peyrefitte avait situé ses
amitiés battu par dire qu'il savait des
choses
oui mais alors ce qui est très étonnant
c'est que votre père en 45 pouvait plus
travailler la terre il était malade et
alors vous avez pris ça comme c'est
bizarre parce qu'ils étaient les
s'occuper il est passé directement du
languedoc ou de l'hérault enfin il t'a
et s'occuper d'un bistrot à montreuil
qui s'appelait chez rené et votre père
vous début vous avez trouvé cette
décision un peu un peu étrange quand
même parce que c'est vrai j'avais 13 ans
et demi c'était juste la fin de la
guerre la vérité même pas finie c'était
le 1er avril 45
c'est seulement dans le bouleversement
était telle qu'il était passionnant je
découvrais tout à la fois le le jus
d'ananas les gloss le cinéma américain
en fait tous les gitans les atteindre
est tout à la fois vous avez fait un
roman donc ça peut votre premier de mon
cas on en avait parlé dans gbagbo lui
est ensemble et qui s'appelait les arts
et le barça pelle chez achille m'enfin
c'est exactement il a disparu maintenant
malheureuse avant il est devenu une
banque
riche idée temps c'est là tout votre
destin dépend d'une grande partie de mon
de mon désir de d'écouter les autres
venus du fait que je passais des heures
à regarder comme ça avant à cabourg et
écouter à regarder de sept étrangers
dont on disait qu'elle était avec un
humour sans veiller le dire que le 0% la
playbook est alors votre deuxième chance
c'est finalement d'avoir on vous a
demandé de lever lisez les
les films de tati a nommé monsieur hulot
vous avez rencontré pierre et d'y aller
avec ça et puis alors deuxième chance
enfin troisième chance et d'une unité
complétée en contact avec une maison par
l'intermédiaire de micheline rozan quai
qui s'occupait de moi à l'époque et de
serge c'est berman qui était son
producteur et il m'a envoyé avec je
crois de trois ou quatre autres jeunes
scénaristes français de rencontrer au
festival de cannes oui 63 et donc vous
êtes venant de l'adaptation du journal
d'une femme de chambre là je suis devenu
son scénariste pendant 19 ans et dont
vous étiez enfermés dans des dents des
étions enfermés ensemble parce que vous
travaillez toujours enfermés quand c'est
comme ça les deux alors vu jouer tous
les rôles
mais quand vous êtes journal d'une femme
de chambre donc chacun luis bunuel il
jouait celestini je trouve toujours le
metteur en scène choisit le rôle féminin
après avoir un je ne sais pas pourquoi
j'ai bien joué donc la femme de chambre
qui s'applique y déjoué par jeanne
moreau et qui s'appelait célestine est l
devions donc improvisé notre époque dans
une chambre d'hôtel
et comme il est sourd il fallait que je
crie alors qu'il s'avère le nombre je
t'aime je te veux fils aîné style croit
alors fait c'étaient les des scènes qui
sont toujours amusante et un peu
inquiétante pour ceux qui en sortent en
visite parce qu'au début
silberman un jour vous a dit il faut
quand même que tu le dises nom de temps
en temps je vais vous étiez pas lui dire
non c'est ça quand on est impressionnés
quand on est un débutant qu'on se trouve
en face d'un monument du cinéma il avait
63 ans elle aimerait qu'il avait sortait
de viridiana d'un examinateur
on a envie d'aimer tout ce qu'il vous
propose aurait pas ça qui l'attend vous
ouais il attend même si vous avez 30 ans
de moins une résistance et une objection
alors il a fait venir silverman de paris
qui m'a invité à dîner pour me dire à la
fin dit l'une au oui de temps en temps
il faut lui dire dites moi donc c'est
fini là mais comme une phrase de
flaubert formidable qui dit la bêtise
c'est de vouloir conclure que j'ai
trouvé chez vous donc on génère de la
bêtise je la sors avant de se quitter on
peut me raconter juste l'histoire du
tabouret avec
jouvet et copeaux oui c'était racontez
moi si c'est françois périer qui la
raconte et dont elle je la lui rend une
mise en scène de cartel copeaux à louise
jouer comme assistant et commencer une
mise en scène je ne sais plus quelle
pièce et il dit je vais faire toute la
mise en scène avec un tabouret louis à
je vais apporter mon tabouret très bien
puis se joue et se lève et revient et
porte l'interview et on commence à
travailler disposition des placements de
comédien au bout d'un moment quelque
chose bloque et cocody
il me faudrait un second tabouret louis
vous pouvait m'apporter un second
tabouret et je vais se lève et dit en
salant les concessions comme bons bien
merci beaucoup je bravo et les
corrections de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus